ben-hur the 2016 edition this is
actually the 6th on screen adaptation
have been her I'm convinced that every
30 years or so we're gonna get a new Ben
Hur in like 80 years there's gonna be
Ben Hur 3000 and it's gonna start
Dracula I guarantee it's gonna happen
and Morgan Freeman will be in that one
too
somehow I don't know if you know
anything about this story it's about two
men who grow up as basically brothers
they're not blood brothers but they are
that close and eventually they become
enemies because one is a Jew and one
joins the Roman army but not just
enemies because they're on different
sides of a war these guys are bitter
blood thirsty rivals so when our hero
Judah ben-hur played by Jack Houston is
sold into slavery becomes one of those
guys it has to row a boat for five years
getting whipped he sets out on a path of
revenge to find his former friend played
by Toby Kebbell and kill him this
version of ben hur has a trailer that is
a laughably awful I watched it I saw
Morgan Freeman in those dreadlocks and I
died laughing
I had no anticipation for this movie at
all and I left surprisingly entertained
is this a great movie
no is it better than the most famous
1959 adaptation no it is however a
competent film with mostly well directed
scenes and very good acting especially
from Jack Houston and rodrigo santoro
who plays jesus in this film and his
scenes were actually surprisingly
effective so if you're just going to
this film to have some fun and you don't
care that much about the original and
doesn't bother you that this is yet
another remake that we're getting you'll
probably be able to watch this new
version of Ben Hur and have a good time
because for the most part it's a
competently made film with really good
acting but as I said in my review for
the newest Ghostbusters movie the way I
judge movies that are remaking something
or another adaptation of something is
does it really have a reason to exist
beyond taking a name that you know and
hopefully making some money off of it is
there something this movie does better
than the other versions is there a
reason to justify its existence beyond
making some money I'd be lying if I told
you I wasn't riveted by the finale
chariot race there were parts of the
movie where I thought okay that's really
good you definitely want to see Judah
ben-hur succeed in what he's trying to
do you feel behind him in that way
because Jack Houston does give a very
good performance in this movie Toby
Kebbell though didn't really sell the
conflicted nature that his character has
he was a little OneNote for me in this
film most of the emotion in the movie
just fell flat for me there wasn't that
part where I felt like I was being swept
away or I was being inspired by amazing
emotion I just didn't really feel it the
emotional core of this movie was just
kind of hollow for me and it really
didn't do much of anything better than
the original 1959 version and despite
the fact that this movie does have some
impressive action scenes and some
impressive stunts it's still not as all
inspiring as the things they were able
to accomplish in the original version
because not only was that that long ago
but it just looked more real and that
brings me to my biggest issue with this
movie unfortunately it's the directing
style of the action sequences
it's very jittery very shaky mostly
entirely handheld which made the 3d
experience of this movie truly
headache-inducing I actually went home
from this movie took some excedrin I got
a bad headache from the 3d of this movie
because it's just not a style that lends
to what 3d can do for a movie it's just
too much and I don't usually have these
types of reactions to things like this I
rarely get headaches from 3d I rarely
get motion sickness of any kind but this
movie had that effect on me and I'm not
going to downgrade the film for that for
one specific reason you can see it in 2d
and if you see it in 2d you probably
won't have the terrible experience that
I had with the 3d so I would recommend
seeing in 2d if you decide to see it
this is a good looking movie mostly a
well acted movie mostly Morgan Freeman
does look hilarious in those dreadlocks
but he is pretty good in the movie the
movie is not as bad as I thought it was
going to be it was surprisingly
efficient it's a competent movie but it
just doesn't really do much to justify
its existence beyond being Ben Hur and
it's a name you've heard of and you
might buy a ticket to it I'm going to
give Ben Hur a C+
not a terrible movie better than I
thought it was going to be but still uh
it's just not quite there emotionally
and that's really important in this
story guys thank you so much as always
for watching stay tuned this Sunday
because I'm going to be continuing my
series of Harry Potter reviews
I already did Sorcerer's Stone and this
Sunday is going to be Chamber of Secrets
you guys the best thank you so much once
again for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
you